It's the real
life version of the HBO
series Succession.
Bernard Arnault is the worst
just man in the world,
the head of the LVMH empire.
$500 billion luxury powerhouse home.
Dozens of iconic brands
are that Louis Vuitton, Tiffany,
Dom, Pérignon, Sephora.
It goes on and on.
And like Logan Roy in succession now Mr.
Arnault is looking to one of his children
to take it over.
Melissa Bell is OUTFRONT
He's on the floor.
Tom, explain to me
what he's doing is closing,
terrifyingly closing?
It's like if Santa Claus was a hit man
a magnate and patriarch, I love you,
but you are not serious.
People
preparing his succession
as carefully as he built his empire.
Not Logan Ron,
but the real world's richest man.
74 year old Bernard Arnault worth
more than $230 billion,
having built the world's biggest luxury
goods company,
all the while
very personally raising, educating
and evaluating
his five potential successors.
I think my group is controlled
by my own family.
So instead of looking every day
at the stock market,
I look for the next ten years.
All five, all
no children work for their father.
48 year
old Delfin, the chair of Christian Jr.
Her brother, 45 year
old Antoine,
who is CEO of the holding company
of Christian Dior,
and the three children from Ana's
second marriage
31 year old Alexander,
who's an executive vice
president of Tiffany's.
28 year
old Frederick, who runs Tagg Hoyer.
And the youngest 24 year old Zhong,
the director of development and marketing
and with vitamins watches Division
C telephone.
Because of the chief
he is at once
an attentive father
a good father, but also a merciless boss.
So the children have to work hard.
He has a fairly clear idea
of their qualities and their weaknesses,
and when the moment comes, will be
able to choose
the $500 billion.
LVMH dominates the world of fashion
with some of its biggest names,
like Christian Dior and Louis Vuitton.
It was built through ruthless
acquisition and, like Waystar, is diverse
with vineyards, hotels, restaurants
and newspapers.
I have you beat.
But it is in the treatment
of their children
that the fictional
and real characters diverge.
Far from fostering discord,
I know has ensured harmony,
but with a cold eye on business
nonetheless.
So thank you very much.
The stakes are huge.
The value of the company,
but also the power that it brings.
Like Logan, Roy
Bernard Arnault has cultivated
his relationships
with the powerful
Acquiring a vast media empire
and making LVMH a symbol in France,
its headquarters
stormed by protesters only last month.
But while Arnault has sought
to protect his children,
he's also made it
clear what he expects of them.
Of course,
we understand the level of responsibility
that is ours.
The way we see things
is that my father is super healthy and
going to work.
Ten, 15, 20, 25 years.
His five children
are now working together
in different parts of the group.
But we're very close.
An empire
carefully built
and ultimately soon up for grabs.
But so far without the family drama.
Now, Erin, this succession
story isn't over
since the 74 year old Bernard
Arnault changed
the statutes of the company.
He was due to retire next year.
He's now giving himself till 20, 29.
So some time between now
and then we will find out
who will take over from him.
But if things continue as they have,
it does appear that
he may have achieved the extraordinary
task of
raising and grooming
these five children for succession.
When only one is likely
to take over in the end
with none of the animosity
that you might expect Erin.
All right, Melissa, thank you.
And of course, we shall.